non-minimalists
do you guys have any experience with
like technology fasting like detoxes
around technology
one of the things that i'm really
concerned with um you know i look at my
niece and she's
she's 15 and like if you take her cell
phone away from her
she just goes ballistic like tears start
flowing and you're just like you know
it's it is
she's glued to it in in a way that like
i never was like
really intense but she's also grown up
with it where we didn't have those when
i was a kid
um what are your thoughts on on this
need for constant stimulation
and and how do you guys find balance
there
yeah i think that the tools the
technology that's introduced
uh into our lives i mean a tool is as
good as its user
and uh you know you can take um
uh you can take a hammer and hammer a
nail with it or i can
bludgeon josh over the head with it um i
mean there there are
there are two different or a lot of
different ways to use a hammer so i
you know i think that um when these
things get introduced
we don't we're not luddites we don't
want to shun new technology
but with uh with with something like
minimalism it is a philosophy that can
help someone
to use their equipment a little bit more
intentional it is scary though man
like when i think about teenagers and
how
um they'll be in the same room uh not
talking
yeah yeah yeah i've heard that that's
crazy and
and uh to your to your point of this of
this stimulation i mean
dude the human brain is built for
stimuli we love stimulation man
so the more that this technology comes
out the more
uh the more companies are trying to
stimulate our brains
to get our attention so but then you
know night time rolls around
and you shut off your device and all of
a sudden your brain's been going and it
wants more
and then we start using our devices in
bed and it's just slippery slow yeah it
really is
i mean there are a few rules there you
can put in place like my partner and i
won't use
any screens in the bedroom like no tv in
the bedroom um
no phones in the bedroom um
and and but the the concept you're
talking about here with
with 15 year old being constantly on
their phone
it reminded me of a few things one is
there was this art exhibit i saw
of uh no it was photos it was a bunch of
photos of people
uh this photographer took photos of
families who were on their phones but
then
photoshopped the the phones out of their
hands
and we look crazy i mean we truly you
imagine
the three of us just sitting here we're
all on our hand just staring at our
blank hands
people would think we had some sort of
mental disorder oh for sure
and um my doctor calls this the the
medium cognitive load
um we did i did a podcast with him we
were talking about health problems and
one of the things we talked about was
this link between mental health and
constant stimulus
but he was talking about how one of the
worst ways to work out is just
run at that medium pace a six or a seven
for
hours on end right it's it's not the
best thing for your body we're doing the
same thing to our minds with
the constant stimuli it's the opposite
of um
are you familiar with cal newport deep
work uh yeah
i haven't uh deep worked the book yeah
it's a he's a professor at georgetown
um i have it on audible but i haven't
listened to it you'll love it
and he he on his blog check out his blog
too he writes a lot about digital
minimalism
he also has a great tedx talk called
quit social media
and um he he's not a luddite he's
younger than us for sure he's late 20s
early 30s
but has never had a social media account
and wright's very eloquently
as to why he's not shunning technology
in fact he's bracing
embracing different types of technology
to allow him to do
more deep work as opposed to that um
the the medium cognitive load where yeah
you can stimulate yourself for 20 hours
a day
but is it meaningful yeah yeah i mean
when it comes to these new technologies
i mean with kids
it's like as a parent you don't have to
order your kid around like tell them
exactly what to do when to do it yeah
but you know it's so easy for me to say
this not being a parent too
but you know i i i i steal this from uh
joshua becker
um he's got a great book um oh my
goodness it's slipping me the more of
less
no the minimalism with kids clutter-free
with kids
clutter-free with kids but i totally am
stealing from that where he talks about
how
you don't tell your kids what to do but
you do want to set some boundaries and i
think like that
with the 15 year old i mean you don't
want to take their phone away forever
right but you know maybe some boundaries
need to be do need to be set but i think
about
not just if i have kids but with myself
i mean josh was talking about
how him and uh bex don't have you know
screen time uh in
in bed and it's you know mariah and i
uh setting these boundaries for
ourselves implementing these rules it
allows us to
um have the household that we want and
yeah if we have kids in our lives like
we're gonna
you know set those boundaries for them
as well but certainly with
all of the devices we have to stimulate
us
we do have to have some boundaries
because if we don't then it gets out of
control and
and we end up even as adults we need to
have them you know
absolutely i try to find a little bit of
time just to be bored
and i think if people think of bored as
like that's such a negative word
they're just like oh to be bored oh that
sounds horrible it's got a citation
right exactly so
i actually like that people think it's
negative i'm like well i want to go do
that and see what that feels like
and like maybe like embrace that and see
if it takes me in a different direction
or a different space in my head and
and so you know if we could just all sit
around and be a little bored you know mr
rogers did this great thing where
he was on uh tv and he's like kids what
is a minute like what does it mean what
does it mean to be a minute
and he started the timer and they
literally on television
watched a clock go around for a minute
and then when it was up he's like
there you go that's a minute can you
imagine
like kids it would not fly today at all
it's funny i was just at the the
portland art museum this morning
and there's this uh photographer um
robert flick which by the way flick is a
great last name for photography oh yeah
he had to have changed that at some
point um
but he's from canada i believe but but
moved to los
angeles and still lives in los angeles
but he spent two years when he first
moved there
photographing a parking structure for
two years
wow and the photos there i i walked
around the whole museum this morning
and they were the most striking out of
all the photos there
there are no cars and no people he made
sure he photographed this parking garage
it's a massive parking garage
only when there were no cars and no
people present
and what what i i
connected this because the boredom thing
like there is a certain banality
in that this parking structure but
there's also beauty
in the banality and then i think the
opposite is also true we're so over
stimulated you know by these things that
seem extraordinary
an ipad that's magic to someone from 100
years ago oh yeah
and but it's so extraordinary but
there's
banality in the extraordinary as well
because if we're constantly passing
i mean now we just see people there's
that the the
famous sort of memed video of this
little baby who
who encounters a print magazine for the
first time and
and she's she just puzzled because she
can't figure out how to swipe left on
the magazine cover
because the stupid print magazine is not
swiping
and and and and so it's a weird thing
how we we've developed this
extraordinary world
but it's not as extraordinary as we
thought and there are
i mean i was blown away by these photos
of a damn parking garage because of the
the light
and the angles and and the structure and
and and the the surfaces and there was
something just
beautiful about the banal
you